as lawyers gather there's a lot at stake
not just the 1.6 billion dollars damages
claimed by Dominion but also the nature
of the protections afforded by the First
Amendment which provides for freedom of
the press
in Focus are the decades-old Supreme
Court rulings which provided sweeping
protection for media companies even when
they disseminate false information
it's not enough for Dominion to prove
Fox was wrong in its allegations it also
needs to prove that the media company
knew the claims are wrong but continued
to broadcast them regardless they would
have to show first of all in terms of
liability
that
fox acted with actual malice or Reckless
disregard for the truth
and then secondly
if the jury is satisfied as to that
that there's been proof of the actual
damages that were incurred by the
plankton so those two things would have
to be found by the juror
already thousands of internal
Communications within Fox have been made
to public in legal documents these
appear to show that the company's hosts
like Laura ingrahim were privately
skeptical of the vote rigging
allegations
as were other network heavyweights like
Sean Hannity
and Tucker Carlson who in private emails
describe Donald Trump's claims of vote
rigging as disgusting
Dominion alleges that despite these
private opinions Fox continued to
publicly and actively support Trump's
baseless claims of vote rigging and
minions alleged role in that the reason
says Dominion the media Network did not
want to alienate the significant number
of trump supporters who are its viewers
Delaware Superior Court Judge Eric Davis
has already ruled that fox on-air
personalities and Executives will have
to testify including the company's CEO
Rupert Murdoch and his son and fox
co-chairman Lachlan
who Dominion alleges knew the claims
were false but did nothing to stop them
being broadcast
the trial is expected to last six weeks
but the potential consequences to the
application of the First Amendment could
last very much longer
Mike Hannah Al Jazeera Washington
work is now underway to repair